we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
why don't we go to our next caller
from the 507 area code caller from 5 1 7
what's your name and where you're
calling from hello my name is Shari and
I'm calling from Michigan great what's
on your mind today
well I received the gift recently from a
family member and there were a few
things on it but threw up some red flags
for me I just wanted to get your opinion
on it ok um the brand name is iFrogz
all lowercase ifr OG z the product is
called toxics toxi x ear pollution and
these are earbuds and the company was
this product was copyrighted in 2016 in
Midvale Utah which is Chaffetz territory
ok and the international office is in
Ireland it has a warning on the product
that says this product contains
chemicals known to the state of
California known because cancer birth
defects and or reproductive harm right
and it's just so blatant that they're
calling it toxic air pollution what ok
so let me let's see if we can break this
down into a couple different things that
note by the way is something that
appears about this has been in
California a possible carcinogen I
ordered some pencils on Amazon and they
came with that note and I was like wait
hold on a second pencils now cause
cancer and I researched it and basically
what it is is that if you end up pencils
could be turned into sawdust and if you
inhale sawdust it's possible that it's
carcinogenic so that warning is being
used really really broadly for a lot of
products that are or could be sold in
California and what I determined was
like
at least with regards to the pencils
that I ordered unless I'm snorting the
shavings it's not going to be something
I particularly need to worry about but
I'm not sure I understand how specific I
don't I don't I don't know about that
but as someone in health care my concern
would be more about people chewing the
pencil and the contents of the paint hmm
that's on the pencil but so I guess I'm
not totally sure with that would be a
more iFrogz thing what is your specific
question well first of all the how do
you feel about I mean the blatant see of
the fact that they are specifically
calling this toxic air pollution they're
labeling it with this reproductive harm
thing which I know anything that sold in
California requires that label and
people can disregard that but that is
because they have a higher standard as
far as the things that they'll expose
their population to right well again I
know nothing about the we are benefiting
personally nothing about the product and
I really would not be able to comment
and and I I just have never heard of
this product I don't know why someone
would call their product toxic it sounds
odd to me and I really wouldn't be able
to comment on it unfortunately one way
or the other and and on that note I
think I think I'm gonna have to move on
Pat because I can't it's just not a
product I've heard of you know what I
mean yeah it's not really our expertise
I would say yeah I think that that's
fair